okay speaking of self-inflicted
disasters for Donald Trump yesterday
Donald Trump shared a video of a
supporter of his yelling white power at
protesters in a Florida retirement
community called The Villages Trump
thanked the great people supporting him
in this video one of whom is an older
white man who yelled white power as he
drove by opponents of Donald Trump's in
a golf cart it's sort of like the
epitome of privilege a white guy in
Florida in a golf cart driving by
protestors standing out in the heat
yelling white power at them and trump's
exact tweet was thank you to the did can
you believe this is reality thank you to
the great people of the villages the
radical left do nothing Democrats will
fall in the fall corrupt Joe is shot see
you soon here's the video Trump was
referring with that comment and you'll
hear just I think it like the eight or
nine second mark you hear this guy yell
white power white power of course is the
calling card phrase of white
supremacists and racists all over the
world that has been for many many
decades so this quickly became another
disaster for Donald Trump he ultimately
had to delete the video from his Twitter
timeline and the White House's
explanation is Trump didn't hear anyone
say white power in the video now when
you look at the video the white power
thing is eight seconds in Trump didn't
see or hear anybody say white power so
this in and of itself is insane and
crazy but there's an entire other part
to this over the weekend news reports
were published in the New York Times
that Russia was reportedly paying people
to kill us and coalition forces soldiers
members of the military in Afghanistan
and offering bounties offering cash
rewards and the White House has
completely fallen all over itself trying
to explain this away saying while Trump
was never briefed on it
well actually the National Security
Council had it but they didn't go to
Trump because it didn't seem credible or
whatever first of all if that's true if
it is true why didn't Trump get briefed
in the sense that even if it these are
such serious allegations that even if
they are untrue if it got to the
National Security Council Trump should
have been briefed on it we're gonna deal
with that more later but there have
started to be the claims made that Trump
tweeted a white power video to distract
from the Russian Bounty's scandal and I
have to tell you I don't buy it
III don't believe Trump's base cares
about the white power video and I don't
believe Trump's base cares about the
Russian Bounty's video I think this is
just Trump being Trump it just happens
that both of these things things
happened at about the same time Trump's
base either doesn't care or doesn't
believe that Trump is even racist it's
not going to help Trump it's not going
to help remove Trump to point out that
he's racist I don't think that that is
really why Trump would do this and
Trump's approval rating is sliding but
it's sliding because of the coronavirus
Fiasco the economic Fiasco Trump's
reaction to saying let's respond to
police brutality protests by saying send
in the military and use even more force
his racist dog whistles have been around
a long time they didn't hurt him in 2016
I think that this is just Trump being
Trump I don't believe it's oh my god
this Russian bounty story is terrible
let me tweet a guy saying white power to
make the news talk about that I don't
see it that way let me know if you
disagree I'm on Twitter at D Pakman I
look forward to hearing from you there
and remember that you can get the daily
audio podcast which set new records last
week stunning powerful records you can
get the audio podcast on any platform
you prefer iTunes stitcher I Heart Radio
Spotify Pandora all of them it's
available on all of them and we'll be
right back after this if you love
feeding your intellectual cure
ah city but you're always struggling to
find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blinking
cast lets you consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video